let me ask you about identity we talked
about the avatar
how do you see identity in the metaverse
should the avatar be tied to your
identity
or can it be
can i be anything in the metaverse like
can i be whatever the heck i want can i
even be a troll so there's there's uh
there's a exciting freeing possibilities
and there's the darker possibilities too
yeah i mean i think that there's going
to be a range right so we're working on
for expression and avatars
um
on one end of the spectrum are kind of
expressive and cartoonish avatars and
then on the other end of the spectrum
are photorealistic avatars and
i just think the reality is that they're
going to be different use cases for
different things um and i guess there's
another axis so if you're going from
photorealistic to expressive there's
also like representing you directly
versus like some fantasy identity and i
think that they're going to be things on
on all ends of that spectrum too right
so you'll want photo like in in some
experience you might want to be like a
photo realistic dragon right or um or
you know if i'm playing onward or which
is this military simulator game um you
know it's you know i think getting to be
more photorealistic as a soldier and
that um could enhance the experience um
there are times when i'm hanging out
with friends where i want them to
you know know it's me so a kind of
cartoon ish or expressive version of me
is good but
there are also experiences like
you know vr chat does this well today
where
a lot of the experience is kind of
dressing up and wearing um a fantastical
avatar that's almost like a meme or is
humorous so you you come into an
experience and it's almost like you have
like a built-in icebreaker because like
you you see people and you're just like
all right i i like i'm cracking up at
what you're wearing because that's funny
and it's just like where'd you get that
or oh you made that that's you know it's
awesome um
whereas you know okay if you're going
into a into a work meeting maybe a
photorealistic version of your real self
is is going to be the most appropriate
thing for that so i think the reality is
there aren't going to be
there is it's not just going to be one
thing um
you know my my own sense of
kind of how you want to
express identity online has sort of
evolved over time in that you know early
days in facebook i thought okay people
are gonna have one identity and now i
think that's clearly not gonna be the
case i think you're gonna have all these
different things and and there's utility
and being able to do different things so
um
some of the technical challenges that
i'm really interested in around it are
how do you build the software to allow
people to seamlessly go between them
so say
so you could view them as
just completely
discrete points on a spectrum but
let's talk about the metaverse economy
for a second let's say i buy a digital
shirt
for my photorealistic avatar
which by the way i think at the time
where we're spending a lot of time in
the metaverse doing a lot of our work
meetings in the metaverse and etc i
would imagine that the economy around
virtual clothing as an example is going
to be quite as big why wouldn't i spend
almost as much money
in investing in my my appearance or
expression for my photorealistic avatar
for a meeting this is i would for the
whatever i'm gonna wear in my video chat
but the question is okay so you let's
say you buy some shirt for your photo
realistic avatar
wouldn't it be cool
if there was a way to basically
um
translate that into a more expressive
thing for your kind of cartoonish or
expressive avatar and there are multiple
ways to do that you can view them as two
discrete points and okay maybe you know
if a designer
sells one thing then it actually comes
in a pack and there's two and you can
use um either one on on that but but i
actually think this stuff might exist
more as a spectrum in the future and
that's what
i do think the direction on some of the
ai advances that is happening to be able
to especially stuff around like style
transfer being able to take um you know
a piece of art or or express something
and say okay paint me you know this
photo um
in the style of gogan or you know
whoever it is that you're you're
interested in um you know take this
shirt and put it in the style of what
i've designed for my expressive avatar
um
i think that's going to be pretty
compelling and so the fashion you you
might be buying like a generator like a
closet that generates a style
and then
like like with the gans they'll be able
to infinitely generate outfits thereby
making it uh so the reason i wear the
same thing all the time is that don't
like choice you're talking about you've
talked about the same
thing but now you don't even have to
choose your closet generates your outfit
for you every time and so you have to
live with the outfit it generates
i mean you could do that although i i no
i think that that's i think some people
will but i think like
i think there's going to be a huge
aspect of
of just people doing creative commerce
here so i think there is going to be a
big market around people designing
digital clothing um but the question is
if you're designing digital clothing do
you need to design if you're if you're
the designer do you need to make it for
each kind of specific discrete point
along a spectrum
or you design are you just designing it
for kind of a photorealistic case or an
expressive case or can you design one
and have it translate across these
things um you know if i did if i buy a
style from you know a designer who i
care about and now i'm a dragon you know
is there a way to morph that so it like
goes on the dragon in a way that makes
sense um and that i think is an
interesting ai problem because you're
probably not going to make it so that it
like that designers have to go design
for all those things but the more useful
the digital content is that you buy in a
lot of uses
in a lot of use cases
the more that economy will just explode
and that's a lot of what you know all of
the um
you know
we were joking about nfts before but i
think a lot of the promise here is that
if the digital goods that you buy are
not just tied to one platform or one use
case they end up being more valuable
which means that people are more willing
and more likely to invest in them and
that
that just spurs the whole economy
you